เมื่อกี้
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงปุ๋ยสวัสดีค่ะนัดเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนใครแล้วครูฟ้า
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 26 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้
วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
25 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตตปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ 5
วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
27 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมสวยผู้ชายจันทร์ปีพตต
ปีพตต 2565
ปีนี้คศ
ปีคศ 2  022 ไหมค่ะมาตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
13:00 น 13:00 นกี่นาที
บ่ายโมง 12 นาทีค่ะบ่ายโมง 12 นาทีนะคะ
ครูฟ้า
อยู่บ้านหยุดอยู่บ้าน
ใช่ไหมคะ
มาอยู่นี่ World  Disney ฟ้านะคะนักเรียน
แล้วก็รู้ฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่บ้านใช่ไหมเนี่ย
แต่กูฟ้าก็อยู่บ้านครูฟ้าอยู่มานานต้อง
ค่ะค่ะหนูแล้วคุยกันแล้วยังผู้หญิงก็มีคำ
ถามถามครูฟ้าค่ะอ่ะ
เนื้อครีมจะถามอะไรกูปลาค่ะครูฟ้าอยู่
บ้านไงคู่หญิงก็เลยอยากเจออยากถามแล้วก็
อยากรู้ด้วยว่าระหว่างบ้าน anal บ้านแล้ว
ก็ปี
Condominium
[เพลง]
คอนโดมิเนียมนะคะนักเรียนไม่ใช่
อพาร์ทเม้นท์นะ Condominium ส่วนส่วนใหญ่
ก็จะมี 1  2 ถึงประมาณซะ
30 ชั้น
แล้วก็มีสระว่ายน้ำสมัยไฟฟ้าเนี่ยไปว่าย
น้ำได้มีฟิตเนสอันนี้คือ Condominium
ครูฟ้า
ใสอยู่บ้านนะก็เลยอยากมาว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ชอบอะไรมากกว่ากันระหว่างบ่ห่างบ้านกับ
Condominium
วิ
ถามก่อนทำก่อนแค่ว่าชอบอะไรมากกว่ากัน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตั้งแต่เด็กๆนะคะตั้งแต่เด็กๆ
ตั้งแต่เด็กๆรู้แล้วเอานี้ผู้ชาย
ตั้งแต่เด็กเป็นผู้ชาย
โตมาเป็นผู้หญิง
นักเรียนรู้หมดเลยนะฮะตั้งแต่อายุ 1 ขวบ
เนี่ยตั้งแต่เด็กๆครูฟ้าเดียวชอบ
คอนโด
หรอ
ใช้ว่าชอบคอนโดบุหรี่หญิงคือว่าเอาฟ้า
เนี่ยตั้งแต่เด็กๆนะฮะจะพูดมาตั้งแต่เด็ก
ๆมาอยู่ที่บ้านเนี่ยนักเรียนตั้งแต่อายุ 1
ขวบข้อ 2 ขวบ 3 ขวบจนยี่สิบหกขวบเนี่ยกู
ฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้านนะคะ 26 ปีค่ะ
26 ปีอยู่ที่บ้านฟ้าก็เลย
อยู่ที่บ้าน
เยอะแล้วอ้ะนักเรียนอยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านบ้าน
อยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านนะคะแล้วก็ฟ้าเนี่ยก็จะ
ชอบคอนโดมากเวลาไปคนโดเพื่อนไปคอนโด
อาร์มคุณพ่อคุณแม่
คนอื่นนะคะอย่าพอแบบกุมภาก็รู้สึกว่ากูไป
ในชอบคอนโด
ได้ครูฟ้าชอบคอนโดใช่ไหมครูอันนี้คือคำ
ถามข้อที่ 1 คำถามข้อที่ 2
ให้อาหาร
สมมติว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีเงินมีเงินซักถ้ามี
บัตร 100 ล้านละกันเยอะหน่อย
[เพลง]
100 ล้านบาทนะคะหน้ามีเงินนะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
จัดซื้อหรืออะไรระหว่างบ้านกับคอนโด
คือบ้านเนี่ยบ้านเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็จะได้บ้าน 1
หลังนี้นะบ้าน 1 หลังแล้วก็จะมีห้องใช่
มั้ยห้องอ่ะจะมีห้องนอน 3 ห้องนี้ห้องนอน
เตียงห้องน้ำมีห้องครัวอธิบานแต่ถ้าคอนโด
กับ 100 ล้านก็อาจจะได้คอนโด 1 ชั้น
เหมือนๆเป็นแบบเห็นเขาก็คือ Tank ฉันเป็น
ของครูฟ้า
มุ่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีเงินก็จะเลือกซื้ออะไร
ระหว่างหมู่บ้านหรือคอนโดมิเนียม
นั่นแหละครูบาก็รวยแล้วเนี่ยซื้อของอย่าง
ไม่ได้เหรอไอ้ไดร์ค่ะซื้ออย่างเดียวค่ะ
บ้าน 1 หลัง 100 ล้านบาทหรือคอนโด 1 ห้อง
1 ชั้น 100 ล้านบาทครูฟ้าจะเลือกซื้อ
อะไร
ถ้าเป็นครูฟ้าหรอ
คือตอนนี้เนี่ยไฟฟ้าก็อยู่ที่บ้านใช่ไหม
ไปศาลแล้วกูฟ้าก็จะอยู่แค่ในห้อง
ก็ไม่ไปที่ไหนอ่ะฮะแต่ว่า
หรอเรื่องภูฟ้า
กูฟ้าจะเลือกให้นั้นลาย
อุบะจะเลือกซื้อ
บ้านอ้าวแต่ครูก็บอกว่าชอบคอนโด
ทำไม
ทำไมครูฟ้าเลือกซื้อบ้านค่ะ
แล้วผู้หญิงลบออกก็ได้จริงๆอ่ะครูบาก็ชอบ
คอนโดนะคะกูฟ้าเลือกซื้อบ้านแต่ครูฟ้าก็
ยังชอบคอนโดอ้าว
แล้วทำไม
ทำไมครูฟ้าถึงเลือกซื้อบ้านเหรอคะไม่
เลือกคอนโดบ้านดีกว่าคอนโดยังไง
เพราะว่ากูไปคิดว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะจะลบนะนายค่ะเพราะครูฟ้า
เนี่ย
อะไรคะแมว
แมว
แมวอีแมวอี
[เพลง]
ฮะ
ซึ่งแมวคู่ฟ้าเนี่ย
ก็น่าจะคือจริงๆอยู่ Penthouse หรือว่า
คอนโดเนี่ยบางทีมันก็เลี้ยงแมวได้เนาะได้
ค่ะได้ได้แต่ครูบาคิดว่าแมวครูฟ้า
น่าจะชอบบ้านมากกว่า
เนาะคิดนะเพราะว่าแบบบ้านเนี่ยมันมีพื้น
ที่ใช่ไหมครูต้นไม้มีต้นหญ้าเนาะแมวคู่
ฟ้าได้มันมาวิ่งได้ไงๆวันก็เลยคิดว่าแมว
ฟ้าน่าจะชอบบ้าน
มากกว่าครูฟ้าเลือกซื้อบ้านเพราะดูจากแมว
จะต้องหาถ้าแมวชอบบ้านกูเขาก็ซื้อบ้าน
ง่ายๆ
โอเคเข้าใจได้นั่นอาหารซึ่งเป็นจริงๆก็
เพราะว่าโป้ขาเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่คนเดียวเอง
เจ็บนะนอกจากครูพระจะมีแมวแล้วเค้าก็ยัง
มีมีใครอีกคะครูฟ้าก็ยังมีพ่อก็เกี่ยว
อร่อยได้ไหมคะ
แนะหน้าจอแตกๆอ้ะมันก็มีพ่อมีแม่มาเห็น
เส้นสีแดงใช่ไหมเนี่ยเขียนได้แค่นี้แหละ
ก็ยังอันนี้กูฟ้าเนาะความอันนี้กุ้งปลานะ
คะแต่คุณตอนนี้ฟ้าอยู่กับคุณยายด้วย
ตาไม่อยู่แล้วอยู่กับคุณยายแล้วก็ผู้ฟ้า
ก็จะมีคุณป้าคุณน้า
มีนัดเขยคนนี้เป็นน้าเขยเนาะแล้วก็น้อง
สาว
อะไรเงี้ยกูบ้านคูฟ้านะคนเยอะมากเลยพอ
แล้วกูมาก็คิดว่า
แล้วก็ยังมีคุณป้ามีพี่สาวมีพี่ชายอยู่
ต่างประเทศด้วยนะปลามายกลับมาไทยเนี่ยก็
จะได้อยู่ที่บ้านด้วยกัดหรือว่าเออ
100 ล้านบาทใช่ไหมคะ 100 ล้านบาทเนี่ย
น่าจะซื้อบ้านได้หลังใจมากๆ
หลังใหญ่มากๆค่ะนักเรียนเลยคู่ฟ้าเนี่ยคน
เยอะอยู่แล้วถ้าครูป๊าอยู่คนเดียวกูเขาก็
จะเลือก Penthouse ว่าเพนเฮ้าส์หรือว่า
คอนโดไม่ใหญ่มากโอเคใช่มั้ยไม่เหงาอ่ะ
อ้ายถ้าอยู่คนเดียวแล้วอยู่ที่บ้าน
ไม่โอเคเนาะก็เลยว่าเลยเลือกกูฝากเขาคือ
ครอบครัวใหญ่นะคะครอบครัวใหญ่คือมีคนคนคน
มีคนในครอบครัวเยอะๆแล้วครูหญิงล่ะถ้า
เป็นครูหญิงจะเลือกอะไรระหว่าง
บ้าน
หรือคนแล้วค่ะว่ารอเรือ
หรือ
คอนโด
ครูหญิงนาคะจริงๆผู้หญิงก็มีครอบครัวนะ
เธอมีเขาก็คือมีคุณอันนี้กูหญิงเนาะผู้
หญิงก็มีกับพ่อไม่มีนะคะมีแม่มีคุณตาล็อก
คุณตาไม่มีมีคุณยังไงมีน้องมีน้องจะมีก็
มีแค่นี้เองอ่ะค่ะก็จะมีครูเอ๋นะคะ
แค่นี้ไงผู้หญิงเนี่ยฟ้ามีครูเบญไม่เข้า
ใหม่ๆนะคะนั่นแหละผู้หญิงคิดแล้วค่ะครู
ฟ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยจะเลือก
Condominium ค่ะอ่ะพี่ปุ๋ย
คะนั้น Hand ไม่ต้องลุ้นแล้วค่ะครูหญิง
เลือกคอนโดมิเนียม
ทำไมผู้หญิงทำไมไม่ซื้อบ้าง
คือผู้หญิงคิดกรุงเทพฯไงระหว่างบ้านที่
ครุงเทพหรือคอนโดมิเนียมที่กรุงเทพฯผู้
หญิงก็เลยเลือก Condominium เพราะว่า
Condominium เนี่ยส่วนใหญ่นะคะมันก็จะ
อยู่ติด
อยู่ติดถนน
อยู่ใกล้รถไฟฟ้าใช้อยู่ใกล้ BTS อยู่ใกล้
ซับเวย์อยู่ใกล้ๆรถไฟฟ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่
ไม่ชอบไม่ขับรถอ่ะคะอ่ะไม่ขับรถรถเนี่ย
ไม่นะคุยก็เลยคิดว่าถ้าครูหญิงซื้อบ้าน
ที่ครุงเทพคะครูหญิงต้องมีรถต้องขับรถงู
แล้วก็บ้านก็จะอยู่ไกลใช่มั้ยอยู่ข้างนอก
อยู่ข้างนอกเมืองไม่ใกล้รถไฟฟ้า
ไม่ใกล้กับ
พารากอน Central  World  shopping  center
ค่ะครูหญิงชอบช็อปปิ้งเซ็นเตอร์นะคะก็เลย
คิดว่า
เลือกคอนโดแล้วก็
สอง
อะไรคะ
บ้านเนี่ยมันใหญ่ใหญ่ใช่ไหมวะผู้หญิง
เนี่ยไม่ชอบถูบ้าน
บ้านฮะเหมือนกูฟ้าเลยไม่ชอบใช่ทำบ้านซื้อ
ไหมบ้านเนี่ย 100 ล้านเนี่ยหลังใหญ่มาก
ทุกวันทุกวันตื่นนอนมาโอ้
บ้านไม่โอเคและก็ต้องมีไหมใช่ไหมมีไม้
เนี้ย
เนี้ยแล้วก็มีถังน้ำ
แล้วก็ถูกบ้านเราบ้านหลังใหญ่คือต้องถูถู
ถูบ้าน
เหนื่อยค่ะคุยก็เลยคิดว่าโอ้
คอนโดมิเนียมถึงแม้จะเป็นเพ้นท์เฮ้าส์
หลังใหญ่เสื้อใช่ไหมทั้งฉันแต่ว่าก็เล็ก
มากกว่าบ้านไงครูฟ้า
งงเห็นนี้นี่เองนะมันก็ยังโอเคกว่า
สายค่ะโอเคกว่า 1 ใช่เอาหินพ่อกูฟ้าก็ไม่
ชอบทำความสะอาดบ้านไม่ชอบถูบ้านเหมือนกัน
กับจ่ายคือไม่ชอบบ้านใหญ่ๆมันเหนื่อยแต่
ว่ามันครูฟ้าแด่ครอบครัวใหญ่ใช่ไหมล่ะ
ครอบครัวอย่างไงก็ต้องมีบ้านแล้วก็อีก
อย่างนึงนี้นะคะภูฟ้าที่กูหญิงคิดว่าไม่
อยากอยู่บ้าน
ทำไมคะผู้หญิงแล้วก็นิบ้านใช่ไหมถ้าหลัง
เนี่ยบ้านครูหญิงก็จะมีแบบบ้าน
แล้วก็บ้านแล้วก็บ้านเนี่ยสวยบ้านหลังที่
1 บ้านหลังที่ 2 บ้านหลังที่สามเนี่ยเรา
เรียกว่าเพื่อนบ้าน
ผู้หญิงไม่พบเพื่อนบ้านคุย
อันนี้ก็จะมีสามียิงภรรยาว่ามีสามีภรรยา
แล้วก็มีลูกเนี้ยจะเป็นผู้หญิงอยู่คน
เดียวแต่นี้ผู้หญิงก็เนี่ยจะเป็นครูฟ้า
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนบ้านผู้หญิง
เนี่ยไม่ชอบไม่ชอบเจอไม่ชอบคุยแบบสวัสดี
ค่ะค่าหญิงถ้าไม่ชอบและไม่ชอบไม่ชอบ
ไม่ชอบ
ถ้าชอบไม่ชอบเพื่อนบ้าน
เพื่อนบ้านเนี่ยบ้านอะไรนะก็คือถ้าผู้
หญิงมีบ้านครูฟ้ากระบี่เนี่ย
ใช่ฟ้าสีฟ้าเป็นเพื่อนบ้านเนี้ยผู้ฟ้าก็
จะมาดูแบบอุ้ยทำไมวันนี้ผู้หญิงมีผู้ชาย
มาที่บ้านใครอย่างเงี้ยเออเลยผู้หญิงมี
ผู้ชายมา
เนี่ยไม่ชอบแต่ถ้าอยู่ Condominium ไม่
ต้องคุยกับเพื่อนบ้าน
ขนมไม่ไม่คุยกันนะคะใช่ๆๆค่ะผู้หญิงชอบไง
ก็เลยคิดแล้วว่า
คอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ยดีกว่าบ้าน
[เพลง]
เป็นความคิดที่ดีนะคะบายกับเพื่อนอยู่ใน
คิดว่าเพื่อนบ้านในไทยในอเมริกาในอังกฤษ
ในฝรั่งเศสน่าจะเหมือนกันเพื่อนเพราะวัน
ศุกร์คุยอิ๋งถ้าครูหญิงมีบ้านหลังนี้ใช่
ไหมคะหลังนี้เป็นบ้านครูหญิงเนาะอันนี้
แหละคุณพ่อคุณแม่
คุณแม่ผู้หญิงแหละก็จะคุยคุยกับเพื่อน
บ้านเหมือนกันคุณแม่ก็จะดูเพื่อนบ้าง
หรือว่าแบบบางทีเพื่อนบ้านเนี่ยมีหมา
ใช่ไหมมีหมาเนี่ย
หมามาเพื่อนบ้านเนี่ยก็อาจจะวิ่งเอามามา
มา
ที่บ้านเราเงี้ยเราก็มา
ขี้ข้างหน้าบ้านเราอย่างเงี้ย
หรือผู้หญิงเหลืออะไรเพื่อนบ้านมหาบรร
ผู้ชายเออ
ก็แบบ
เป็นผี
เห็นไหมอยู่คอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ยดีกว่าอยู่
บ้าน
[เพลง]
อยู่ Condominium ใช่ไหมคอนโดมิเนียมแล้ว
โหสูงมากเลยนะภูฟ้า
หน้าพอมินี่ฉันชายค่ะถ้ากูหญิงไม่ได้อยู่
เป็น Penthouse ใช่ไหมอันนี้เนี่ยห้องครู
หญิงว่าก็มีห้องห้องอ่าอาจจะเป็นเพื่อน
บ้านถ้าเพื่อนบ้านคนนี้เนี่ยตายไม่เป็นไร
กูหญิงก็มีทีมทีมสวยไม่กลัว
คือถ้าเป็น House มันไม่อยู่คนเดียวข้าง
บนไงใช่ถ้าเป็นเฮาก็ยิงแบบคนเดียวสบาย
ท่านผู้หญิงก็เลยคิด
คอนโดดีกว่าบ้านก็เลยคิดว่าซื้อคอนโดดี
กว่าซื้อบ้านนะคะเรานักเรียนราคะนักเรียน
คิดยังไงบ้านคอนโดอะไรดีกว่ากันสายเลยนัก
เรียนจะซื้ออะไรใช่ไหมคะครูป่าได้ให้นัก
เรียนก็คอมเม้นท์บอกได้นะคะ
คุณก็ไปก่อนแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอ
หน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ